RICHARD KESSLER: I'm
Richard Kessler.
I'm the dean of Mannes College
at the New School for Music.
And I am really thrilled
to be here today.
We're all thrilled.
We have here some good friends
and colleagues.
We have Kathy Supove on piano,
one of our faculty members.
This is Cathy.
[APPLAUSE]
RICHARD KESSLER: And we have
these wonderful colleagues and
friends and partners, Sideband
here today as well.
[APPLAUSE]
RICHARD KESSLER: And
we have a really
special program for you.
And I'm really excited
to get to it.
Let me start with some
introductions.
First, I'm going to tell
you a little bit
about Mannes College.
We're a 100-year-old music
conservatory that's part of
the New School.
Many of you know the New
School as Parsons.
Or some of you know the New
School as the New School for
Social Research.
We're the music conservatory
at the New School.
And we have three different
divisions.
We have a college division where
we give out degrees, all
kinds of degrees, bachelors
degrees, master's degrees,
diplomas, certificates.
We also have a preparatory
division, where we have
students from the ages of 4 to
18 years old who invade the
school on Saturday and take over
every single space you
could possibly imagine, making
music in every possible way.
And we also have an extension
division, which is for
continuing ed, where adults
come and learn
and engage in music.
It's also a place where we
provide all kinds of courses,
all kinds of classwork.
And there's all kinds of
opportunities for partnership
in the extension division.
Let me read to you--
you'd think I
would know it by heart.
But actually it's fairly new.
And I have actually never read
it to anyone before.
I'm going to read to you our
mission, actually, at Mannes,
because I think it informs the
day to day a little bit.
We're dedicated to stimulating,
supporting, and
advancing the creative role of
music in all aspects of a
rapidly changing society.
Mannes seeks to develop citizen
artists who engage the
world around them in and through
music in traditional,
emergent, and new forms
of practice.
And another way of looking at it
is we're reinventing a very
old traditional model.
And I mean old by something
that's been practiced in
certain ways in classical
music since
the 1400s or 1500s.
We're looking to reinvent
ourselves through new music,
through technology, and a
commitment to community.
And we have our partners here
today to give you a glimpse
and a sense of the kinds of
things we're embarking on.
Sideband is a tremendous model
in terms of how you use
technology to make music
and engage with people.
It's interesting in terms of
its performance quality.
It's interesting in terms
of its research.
And I think it's interesting in
terms of it being a model
for engaging people in all
sorts of new ways.
Now, before we go on with
Sideband and Kathy Supove, let
me first say thanks to the
Google organizers, Kate
Clugston and her team, Melissa
Carroll, John Clemente and his
team, Lee Stimmel,
and Phil Ames.
Thank you very much for
making today possible.
[APPLAUSE]
RICHARD KESSLER: Now, I'd also
like to say there's all sorts
of opportunities to partner with
us, to engage with us in
what we're doing today.
We're looking for friends, we're
looking for supporters,
we're looking for help.
And if you're interested in
working with us, working with
Sideband, working with Kathy,
please contact Kate Clugston.
She'd be the point person within
Google to do that.
OK so now, it's nice to move
on from hearing myself talk
and instead move right
to the music.
So we're going to move to
Sideband, and they have two
pieces that they're going to
play for you back to back.
The first case they're going
to play-- and after they
perform, they're going to
introduce themselves a little
bit, give you history of the
ensemble, background.
It's going to be a good
presentation, but we're
starting with music.
So Sideband is going to do the
first piece, which is called
"Balls," and it's by Konrad
Kaczmarek, and the second
piece, which is called
"In Line," and
it's by Jascha Narvesen.
And it's a 10 minute segment,
and then we'll go to some
questions, but let's go
right to Sideband.
Everyone, welcome Sideband.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN TRUEMAN: My name's
Dan Trueman.
I am one of the founders
of the Princeton Laptop
Orchestra, which we
started in 2005.
I started it with Perry
Cook, professor of
computer science there.
I'm a professor in the
composition department, music
department.
And Sideband, these wonderful
musicians here, this is the
professional outgrowth of the
student group that is the
Princeton Laptop Orchestra.
And the aim of the Princeton
Laptop Orchestra, this was
back in 2005, we wanted to see,
can we figure out how to
make music together
with computers?
Up to that point, classes in
electronic music were always
taught in a studio, and you work
alone, and you make some
fixed product that you share
with people, but the notion of
actually making music together
and finding out what we can do
with computation in a music
making contact really didn't
happen much at that time.
So that was the aim here, and
that's what we're still
working on.
Two pieces there.
The first one, affectionately
referred to as Konrad's Balls,
was done by Konrad Kaczmarek
over there, you saw there.
[APPLAUSE]
And one of the fun things about
that is exploring a
system that you can set things
loose in and see how they
behave, and see what kind
of sounds they make.
And then you saw at the end when
they turned the screens
around, basically, the network
is used to connect their
systems so that their animated
balls can be passed from one
machine to the next and
their sounds can be
collaboratively created.
And then that was followed
directly by Jascha Narveson's
"In
Line." [APPLAUSE]
Lots of fun things to talk about
there, but I think the
obvious thing was using these
game controllers there to try
to get a more physical
engagement with sound.
The first piece, we sit at the
laptops and type away and so
on, and that's all fine and
good, but it's also nice to
get up and actually
be physically
involved with the sound.
And these little game
controllers
here are about $15.
They were made for
a golf game.
They come with little gloves
that your attach
these strings to.
It's very, I guess, it's very
last year, but you swing your
hands with the little plastic
golf club, and then a little
avatar of your golf player
shows up on the screen.
They're fantastic music
controllers.
We had to go in and hack them a
little bit to have them work
for us, but they've become
pretty widely used in laptop
performance around the
world, really.
What else should I say about
that piece or the controllers,
other than that they're really
cool, and I wish
they still made them?
The other thing maybe I'll
comment on briefly are these
shiny little speakers.
And I think these are
particularly relevant to the
kinds of things that Richard
was talking about, thinking
about Mannes and a very old
conservatory focused for a
long time on making music
together in old fashioned
ways, something that I'm
actually very drawn to.
And one of the aims of these
speakers here is to actually,
in some way, enable us to try
to make music together with
computers in a kind of
old fashioned way.
Rather than having each laptop
plugged into a mixer and all
the sound coming through
speakers that are separated
from our bodies and really hard
to associate with what
we're doing ourselves, these
are meant to be near us as
performers, and also they're
meant to fill rooms from the
inside out with sound rather
than projected from the
outside in.
So these are one of the main
characteristics of the
Princeton Laptop Orchestra
and Sideband.
So is that a good enough
summary here?
There will be questions later,
of course, and also, if you
like, you can come try our very
fancy software that we've
built here.
All this stuff, all
these pieces,
we build them ourselves.
The software is all
stuff that we make
ourselves for each piece.
And with that, I think
I'll hand it over.
Kathy, are you next for doing
your piece, or is
Richard going to--
[APPLAUSE]
RICHARD KESSLER:
Thank you, Dan.
Thank you so much.
It's a really interesting thing
when you think about
taking this new technology, new
approaches, and bringing
it into a school that's
primarily been working in
really old modalities.
What happens in terms
of culture shock?
What happens in terms of people
trying to wrap their
head around the technology,
around the meaning in terms of
the practice?
How do you make music with
new technologies?
Can you take the very old
practice and basically wet it
and have it live inside
something like this?
And that's ultimately what we're
trying to do, based on
the model of Sideband and
what Dan has been
explaining to you.
Anyway, my job for the moment is
to introduce Kathy Supove.
Kathe is one of our favorite
faculty members at Mannes.
She's someone who is expert at
teaching adults, someone who's
expert at teaching kids, but
I've known for many years as
one of the leading pianists
in terms of new music, new
approaches.
She's a person that composers
are drawn to when composers
think, who is willing
to try something?
Who's willing to take a risk?
What pianist is interested
in something new?
That's Kathy.
That's her reputation, that's
what she's known
throughout the field.
She does it in an extraordinary
way with a great
commitment, and she's one
of the leaders in the
field of new music.
I'm really thrilled to be able
to introduce her to you right
now, and she's going to tell
you a little bit more about
the piece that she's going
to perform with Sideband.
So everyone, please welcome
Kathy Supove.
[APPLAUSE]
KATHY SUPOVE: I'm just going to
make a few short remarks.
Thank you, Richard, very much.
I hope I can live up to that.
I am a classically trained
pianist, but I ended up being
a pianist that promotes,
premieres, commissions, and
records music by the Beethovens
of today, like some
of the people you see here.
And it's kind of a saga how
I ended up doing that.
I was dissatisfied with a lot
of the things about being a
conventional pianist.
But one of the things that
bothered me about it was it's
a little bit lonely
being a pianist.
You're kind of in this practice
room, and you're with
this one sound of the
instrument, and it's a
fabulous instrument, unequalled
in my opinion, but
you're kind of all
by yourself.
And I always used to think, what
would it be like to play
piano at the beach, or what
would it be like to play piano
in a circus, or various
settings and
that kind of thing.
And I think that has something
to do with how I ended up
migrating toward creating
works with composers or
collaborating with them and
encouraging them to create
works for piano plus
something else.
And today, I'm going to be doing
a piece that's piano
plus an electronic soundtrack.
And one of things a soundtrack
can do, I mean, it can
simulate a chamber music partner
and do that kind of
thing, but the other thing
it can do is create an
environment that you're
playing in.
And so I can feel like I'm
playing piano in some weird,
surreal, historic version of
Bali or something like that.
Anyway, I've found it's just
been really fulfilling.
The name of the piece I'm going
to play is "What Remains
of a Rembrandt," and it's based
on a pamphlet that the
playwright Jean Genet put out,
and it has some kind of very
weird translation.
But basically, what it implies
is what remains of a Rembrandt
if you took away all the
associations that you
conventionally have with it?
And the composer,
Randall Woolf--
by the way, full disclosure, he
is my husband and he could
not be here today,
unfortunately.
But what I think he had in mind
was if you took away all
your conventional notions of the
composer Claude Debussy,
what would you end up with?
And so he's answered
that question.
And just to give away some
secrets, some of the
ingredients that he's used in
the soundtrack that I play
along with is a Debussy opera,
some Vietnamese gongs, and
some kind of gunshot that he
has played around with
electronically so you
can't recognize it.
And he also managed to
throw in my favorite
Debussy piano piece.
And I hope you enjoy it.
This is an excerpt.
It's not the whole piece.
The whole piece is too long for
today, but I hope you'll
enjoy it very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
KATHY SUPOVE: Thank you.
Somehow, I've been drafted to
introduce this next piece, but
it's great because it gives
me a chance to talk about
Sideband a little bit, and
I first heard the Laptop
Orchestra from Princeton fairly
soon after it was
founded, I think, in Carnegie
Hall with the American
Composers Orchestra.
And I immediately thought that
this was a group I wanted to
make music with.
So it's interesting Richard was
talking to you about new
ways of making music, and to
me, it just seems totally
natural for a pianist
to want to play
with a laptop orchestra.
I mean, it's just
totally natural.
Of course.
I mean, they're so at the
forefront in terms of what
they're doing, but at
the same time, but
very musical and appealing.
So it wasn't too long before I
got in touch with Dan Trueman
and asked him about writing
a piece for me.
And it took a few years to
happen, but it did finally,
and it was great.
And a couple of surprises came
along along the way.
Dan wrote a fabulous piece for
me, which you should all hear.
It's coming out on recording
eventually.
I'm sure you can ask Dan
when it will be out.
But I got a couple of
surprises in the
middle of the project.
One was that Michael Early
wrote a piece for me and
Sideband also called "Victorian
Webs," which we're
going to perform
today for you.
And "Victorian Webs," it's
kind of a tribute to the
beginning of Morse code, and
you'll hear some music in it
that, I guess it is
Morse code, and it
sounds like Morse code.
But at the same time, my part is
the Victorian part, and so
this person is going into the
new technology, but at the
same time has a nostalgia for
the old, much the same way as
the computer age has come upon
us and we have nostalgia for
things sometimes.
So we play different roles, and
it's interesting because I
always hear their airport
in my mind.
It goes around, it's kind of in
my ear all the time, and I
notice them going around
humming the
piano part that I play.
So we're kind of each
other's ear worms.
And I also wanted to mention
that Konrad Kaczmarek also let
me play his piece at one point,
and he's a professional
level pianist himself, so I
really appreciate that.
And we very much hope
you enjoy this.
Yes.
Oh, yeah.
Absolutely.
LAINIE FEFFERMAN: Thanks.
Hello.
Hi.
We are just going to introduce
ourselves really quick so you
know who it is making
these noises.
I'm Lainie Fefferman.
I am a composer.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm a composer.
I am about to finish, hopefully,
my Ph.D. in
composition at Princeton.
Everyone on the stage
is somehow
affiliated with Princeton.
I'm new to technology, but I've
got to say Sideband is
making me fall in love with
making music combined with
technology.
By day, I'm a math teacher.
I've been singing a lot,
and I love Google.
I'm happy to be at Google.
Here's Caroline.
CAROLINE SHAW: Hi.
I'm Caroline Shaw.
I'm a violinist and singer
and composer, and also at
Princeton, friends of
Gabe Taubman and Jen
Chang who work here.
You guys are awesome.
Thanks.
ANNE HEGE: Hi.
I'm Ann Hege.
I'm also finishing up at
Princeton with my degree in
composition, and I'm a singer,
and I'm really interested in
movement and sound and
that connection.
DAN IGLESIA: Hi.
I'm Dan Iglesia, composer,
media artist, programmer,
co-leader of PLOrk for
a few seasons,
and member of Sideband.
JASCHA NARVESON: Hi, I'm Jascha
Narveson, former tabla
player, composition major,
computer programmer,
electronic music
type of person.
Also, I feel incumbent upon me
to mention that Caroline Shaw
won the Pulitzer Prize in
composition this year, so you
can just give her a hand.
[APPLAUSE]
KONRAD KACZMAREK: Hi.
I'm Konrad Kaczmarek, also
a graduate composer at
Princeton, finishing up.
I wrote that first piece, the
Balls piece, so if you're
interested in hearing more about
that, please come up
afterwards, ask me.
Thanks.
JEFF SNYDER: Hi.
I'm Jeff Snyder.
I'm not playing on this piece,
but I was on the first two.
I'm a research scholar at
Princeton, and I'm a composer
and improviser, and also
electrical engineer.
So I have a company building
some instruments that, if
you've heard of the
Snyderphonics
Manta, that's me.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
RICHARD KESSLER: Excellent.
Thank you, Sideband,
and Kathy.
Wonderful piece.
I love that piece.
We have about two minutes left
in the formal program.
Those who want to stay
afterwards, you can come up.
You can talk to the
band members.
You can talk to anyone.
They have offered for you
if you want to take
a look at the equipment.
I think we have time probably
for one question.
I also want to remind you if
you want to get involved,
there's a lot of opportunities
to get involved with the band,
with Mannes.
There's all sorts of
things we're doing.
We're creating community
choruses.
We have courses that we offer.
We could be teaching courses
here, too, if you like.
But anyway, context
Kate Clugston if
you want to get involved.
So we have time for one
question, and then afterwards,
certainly, please come
up and ask whatever
questions you like.
Time for one question?
AUDIENCE: Earlier, you played
with that controller, game
controller, with strings
attached.
So Microsoft Xbox has this
motion controller where you
use a video camera to see
how your body moves.
So have you think about tying
that together with the music,
the pianos?
DAN IGLESIA: We as an ensemble
have not tried it.
I personally have developed for
Kinect, making instruments
that use Kinect to detect
objects, detect people.
There are certainly pros
and cons with it.
I, for example, love the
Kinect because lighting
doesn't matter, just physicality
and space matters.
Somebody may write a piece
for us that uses Kinect.
It's certainly a possibility
in the future.
We definitely like these in
terms of being physically
connected, these are
extremely robust.
There's not a lot of jitter
as there is in
some IR camera systems.
But yeah, we're certainly open
to all manner of bizarre
hardware configurations.
AUDIENCE: Great, thanks.
RICHARD KESSLER: All
right, we're at
the end of our program.
Let's have another round
of applause for
Sideband, Kathy Supove.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]